ER V
>>T FRONIRY OF, NAVLE THAT MAN
Y DEVASTAT BY
CONSEQUENCES OF PUTIN'INVASION.
THAT THAT'S TRUE.
TH W OPENLY, A
EVERYBODY UNTATUE MOST TIME ER,
MOVING IN A BACKWA A LOT OFFICUL
'70s AND WERE SOME WHPE THE
DIRECTION IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
GH RUSSI
SCED FROM GLOBAL RK
HAPRE
EVASTATE IEA>> PRESINT ASKED
THIS WBOUT
POS
>> I'MISHELON .O PLAY FORES
T SAN SOME INTI
FIREOR HOUSE
ARREST SOME OF HIS ADVISERS.>> S
HAPPENING?
THAT PUTIN PUT ADVISER
UNDER HOUSE ARREST?
>> I HORS.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO VERIFY
STRO
SITUATION THERNST ANHIWE DON'T
BUT YEAHEXTEND, HE IS
.
THERE IS ANOOF THE
INT  DELIBERATELY
F OF
CTED BUBBLE. IN A
TWO-WAY S
HE DELIBERATELY BUILT A SYSTEM
WHERE HED PEOPLE F
E REALLY ONLY  H THIS IS THE REG
E ADVISE
ABASTED BYHECONSEQUENCES AND KN
ITY, ARE THEY COMMUNICATING H  D
THEYPUTIN? ANY SORT OFCONVERSAT
ANY OF THIS?OR NO?
>> THIS ISER
ETWEEN AND.
SOLL TBIGGER EXTENT THAN THES.
TRY IN THEIRECTION, TH - TAKEN E
CERTAINTY WILL BE ED T
PUTI WHIE E
ABOUT ALE ON
THIS IS AN FTO
S ALL TH
CAN POTELL
POLICIES. N URED, YOU WROTE THAT
PUTIN'S DAYS NUMBERED.
THE EN HAVE MADE NDO TI
REGIME AS WE.OF COURSE IFN POWEI
FI OR HOS OR WHAT HE
COULD DO.
Y SEE T VLADIMIR?
REMAIN I
E TIME.AINTAINS STRONG
MONTHS DOWN THE
MANY INSEM WILL GI
DISCONTENT WE  EXPRE
LOSSES A TO G TU
SOMEON
HE WAS LUCKY ALL.T THIS TIMAROU
OCIETY, THE QUESTIONS
WHE WE GOING, TO LEAD THE
SITUATION.